le but de cette formation s'était en
fait de donner des outils très concret à
ces femmes qui ont des idées de création
d'entreprise de leur permettre de mettre
en oeuvre ces outils et de leur
permettre de réaliser le rêve de
création d'entreprise 35 femmes
aujourd'hui son diplôme et c'est une
satisfaction pour vous à tout à fait
c'est une grande satisfaction parce que
c'est 35 femmes ont reçu un certificat
diplômant donc de l'accord nicolas
jossier paris hec executive education
notamment et ça leur permet déjà d'une
part d'ajouter une ligne à leur cv mais
surtout d'avoir des compétences
supplémentaires pour pouvoir réussir
leur projet d'entreprise on a eu
énormément de succès pour cette
formation nous avons eu 108 inscriptions
nous avons obtenu 35 femmes
vu le succès de cette formation et
ensuite on a vu comment ça s'est passé
donc ça a eu beaucoup de succès nous
avons très forte demande donc nous
prévoyons de refaire une seconde session
au cours du premier trimestre de l'année
2020 oui hcc quelque part sortie de
l'image élitiste en fait tout à fait
c'était ça notre objectif de sortir de
l'image élitiste cacher c'est parce que
s'ils voient que pour le commun des
mortels hec c'est la grande école ce
sont les ministres se sont les jonctions
dans les cabinets ministériels et les
patrons du cac40 abel non hc ce n'est
pas que ça mais hec s'est également
beaucoup de petit stand up qui sont
cohérents france et qui innove au niveau
mondial et hcc aussi des martiniquaises
justement grâce à stand up qui
permettent et en leur permet d'accéder à
leur rêve de création d'entreprise et je
peux vous dire que sur les 35 femmes il
ya des projets d'entreprises qui sont
vraiment magnifiques